une fois n'est pas coutume je ne vais
pas parler pour cette session de
strasbourg de ce qui se passe dans le
parlement mais de ce qui se passe en
grèce un nouveau gouvernement a été élu
en grèce qui a légitimement exprimé un
certain nombre de demandes de
réorientation de politique européenne ça
c'est normal c'est la démocratie mais il
ya quand même quelques excès et quelques
comment dirais-je revendications qui
elles ne sont pas acceptables la
première chose qu'il faut garder à
l'esprit c'est qu'il y a eu des
élections en grèce mais il n'y a pas eu
des élections dans tous les autres pays
d'europe et que donc le gouvernement
grec doit continuer à discuter j'allais
dire presque que ça lui plaise ou pas
avec les partenaires qui étaient là
avant et qui avait obtenu du
gouvernement grec précédent un certain
nombre d'engagements
deuxièmement le gouvernement grec actuel
monsieur de sipera lui même le premier
ministre dans le parlement grec a
réclamé des dizaines et même des
centaines de milliards à l'allemagne au
nom des réparations de la seconde guerre
mondiale cette revendication ne
préoccupe énormément parce qu'elle
révèle une sorte de manque de sens
historique qui est absolument confondant
après la seconde guerre mondiale on a
décidé qu'on allait pas recommencer les
erreurs de la première guerre mondiale
en imposant un traité comme le traité de
versailles qui avait été imposé à
l'allemagne en 1919 sans son
consentement et en appliquant une
logique de vengeance d'humiliation du
vaincu et consiste en fait à extorquer
le maximum d'argent de celui qui avait
perdu la guerre c'est ce qui avait été
fait auparavant d'ailleurs contre la
france en 1870 mais on voit bien quelle
ressentiment cela avait nourri donc
après la seconde guerre mondiale
et pourtant dieu sait si ça a dû être
difficile pour des hommes qui avaient
vécu souvent deux guerres mondiales qui
avaient perdu des proches on a décidé de
changer de logique le plan marshal
américain comme la création de la
communauté
européenne charbon et de l'acier a eu
pour but de remplacer cette logique de
vengeance par une logique de coopération
on a dit qu'on allait essayer de
construire un avenir commun avec les
allemands qui bien entendu avaient pris
leurs distances par rapport aux horreurs
nazies une succession de traiter pour
ceux que ça intéresse les détails champ
sur mon site internet qui ont finalement
abouti au traité du 12 septembre 1990
qui est le traité de paix de la seconde
guerre mondiale même s'il ne dit pas son
nom
aboutit à abandonner la logique de
réparation et dans le traité de 1990 on
a mis fin au conflit on a également
défini les frontières de l'allemagne qui
vit désormais en paix avec tous ses
voisins et je pense notamment à la
pologne donc il serait extrêmement
dangereux et mal venu de ré ouvrir la
boîte de pandore et d'aller déterrer des
cadavres et ils sont nombreux dans les
placards européen du siècle dernier je
crois encore une fois pour résumer que
le gouvernement grec a des arguments à
faire valoir il y à angresse une
pauvreté qui est extrêmement douloureuse
il ya un chômage de masse certaine
mesure que l'europe et le gouvernement
grec ensemble ont mis en place n'ont
peut-être pas produit les effets désirés
ça ça fait partie du débat démocratique
parfaitement normal et légitime en
revanche je crois qu'il serait avisé de
ne pas ouvrir cette boîte de pandore du
passé petite note de bas de page je
constate que les américains ont fait
entendre leur voix et ne cesse de dire
que les européens devraient abandonner
les politiques d'austérité j'aimerais
bien entendre le gouvernement des états
unis dire qu'en 1990 lorsque le traité
de moscou a été signé les états unis ont
été parmi les premiers à
a prôné une solution consistant à dire
que la page était tournée voilà ce que
les américains pourraient faire qu'il ya
dre bien pour eux à être entre
l'allemagne et la grèce et à trouver une
solution au lieu d'être un petit peu en
ce moment je trouve uniquement du côté
des grecs ce qui n'est pas très sain et
ceux qui donnent lieu évidemment en
allemagne à la montée de sentiments peu
amènes d'autant plus qu'il ya dans le
gouvernement grec monsieur de sipera ce
et ont fait alliance avec le parti des
grecs indépendant des personnalités
assez douteuse xénophobe antisémite et
anti allemande voilà c'était un petit
tour par la grèce strasbourg n'est pas
tout à fait athènes mais en ce moment il
s'y passe des choses importantes pour
l'avenir de la zone euro je ne doute pas
d'ailleurs qu'on va finir par entrer
dans une logique de compromis mais
encore une fois après avoir laissé les
démons du passé et les outrances
verbales l'emporté sur la raison c'est
dommage parce que la déesse athéna savez
chez les grecs étaient la déesse de la
sagesse et ont considéré qu'il y avait
un une erreur à ne jamais commettre ces
tomber dans l'excès élus et l'outrance
qu'on appelait en grec l'hubris je crois
qu'il serait bon que ce gouvernement
abandonna l'hubris et reviennent à la
discussion raisonner avec ses
partenaires à bientôt mercier